okay so the book of bubba fed is now
officially over and the finale has a lot
to unpack from it throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
ending in easter eggs giving our
thoughts on the series as a whole and
also talking about the things you missed
yes you search your feelings you know it
to be true now from here on out it's
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then i
highly recommend that you check out now
i find your lack of likes disturbing so
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoyed
the video and don't forget to subscribe
for breakdowns like this each and every
day without the way let's set phases to
pun and get into the book of boba fett
mandalorian grogu training tatooine
fenix shan's show okay so last week was
pretty heavily focused on the
mandalorian luke skywalker and also
grogu boba fett is pretty much just got
to the point that he's standing around
in silence doing nothing which when you
think about it makes him exactly like
how he was in the original trilogy this
is for the real fans now amanda returned
to tatooine and joined up with his
forces and out in the desert cadbane
arrived to deliver a warning to the kind
folks of freetown he shot the sheriff
and also the deputy in order to make it
clear that the pikes weren't messing
around only max rebo was safe as the
sanctuary was destroyed and we ended the
episode with groku having to make a
tough choice will he remain to train as
a jedi or will he go back to be with
mando we'll get into it but that should
have you fully caught up now he opened
on mos esper in the aftermath of the
destruction of the sanctuary amongst the
runes they talk about how prosperous
that they want to make moses bear and it
very much juxtaposes the destruction
that they stand amongst manu tells them
of the deal that they made with kobanth
and how all they want is to stop the
spice from flowing bubba realizes that
it's destroying everyone's lives and he
puts the people above profits this idea
of staying close to those of mos esper
is furthered hammered home by the fact
that fed agrees to remain at the bar
rather than going back to his palace the
name of the bar is of course the
sanctuary and this very much takes on a
literal meaning as the war plays out now
we could decade bane eyeing up some
jawas like he's pelimoto and he joins
the pike leader that we met earlier in
the season in mos eisley along with him
is the mayor who according to his
majordomo was on a scheduled vacation
he's ted cruz in for a bruising and it's
all politics as we learned the pikes
were the ones that killed the tuscans
they framed the neatos and we got our
first fan theory wrong here as i thought
that cad would have done it however it
was pretty obvious that the bikers
weren't behind it as fennec did say they
wouldn't have had the manpower to take
them all out pretty much got every fan
theory wrong to be fair and even the
reports about a dh tan solo showing up
turned out to be untrue it's untrue all
of it now the conversation ends with the
mayor saying that he doesn't want to see
moses but destroyed and this is where
cad states that he has an idea that can
draw them out from here we go to the
title sequence which is in the name of
honor the mandalorians are of course
heavily based around this idea of honor
and this went to the point that mando
was told he wasn't a mandalorian just
for removing his helmet honor is tested
throughout the episode and whether
people want to do the honorable thing
and stay loyal to those that mean the
most to them this is reflected in grogu
mando and most of the characters that
appear in the entry those with no honor
i.e the pikes and catbane end up losing
whereas the ones who stay loyal to the
creed come out on top from here we jump
to luke's x-wing which is being piloted
by none other than r2d2 the shot from
behind somewhat mirrors how jj filmed
them in the force awakens and it's a
cool way to open the scene after the
title sequence unfortunately unlike the
end of the mandalorian season 2 luke
isn't in it but we do get a little small
surprise that comes in the form of grogu
he has decided to return to his father
and instead of becoming a jedi he's
gonna become a mandalorian this was
somewhat hinted at in the expanded law
as ben salah was officially the first
student at luke's academy according to
the kylo ren comics therefore we kind of
knew this would happen in advance so
first fan theory right only fan theory
right to be fair and i'll stop doing
that as that will get very annoying now
as for training i think that he very
much doesn't really need it because in
the last century luke said to ahsoka
that he was remembering things rather
than learning them in you therefore he
likely has a lot of the skills already
which he picked up on core ascent and
thus he doesn't really need to be taught
he lands in pelimoro's hangar and we see
the usual pit droids that accompany her
including the bd droid who may or may
not be from jedi fall in order paly
shouts out to it and calls the pilot
officer because as we've seen x-wings
are now used as the ship that the po-po
poe damerons ride around in when
protecting lauren order pally pulls them
out and says that groga is a terrible
name which may be lucasfilm making jabs
at the fan reaction to learning he
wasn't going to be called baby oda she
shifts down his parker jacket to see the
mithril shirt which indeed confirms that
luke is going to be looking for new
students now as we know his academy fell
and this could be because he was dealing
in absolutes and making kids choose
whether they wanted to hang out at his
crappy house for the rest of their lives
or go and eat space eels the choice was
easy now from here we go back at the bar
and catch the group waiting for the
forces of confant to arrive
unfortunately they don't know that he
was shot last week and thus they have to
wait out for the guys to report back to
them we get a video of the mods
patrolling the three territories which
we learned earlier in the season would
stand back as the war played out however
this isn't really the case and the
aqualish trand oceans and clatunians end
up trying to kill bubba's crew because
the pikes are splitting their profits
with them again these guys lose out
because they have no honor which further
ties into the title of the episode 88
introduces cad bane and barbara of
course recognizes him dunks on him a bit
and there's a really cool call back in
this moment cat says well if it isn't
the quakter calling the stifling slimy
which is actually a call back to the
mandalorian season 2 when boba said it
about katan and koskarevs it basically
means the part calling the kettle black
but i love that this is a phrase that's
used by fett and later cadbane now
cabbane and boba have had somewhat of a
rivalry throughout the entire saga born
on giros bane was based on angel eyes
from the good the bad and the ugly the
gunslinger is one of the most feared
bounty hunters in the galaxy and in a
cruel twist of irony he was mentored by
jango fett after the battle of genosis
khad was hired by several underworld
figures including darth maul count dooku
and also the hutts khad was highly adept
at fighting jedi and he completed
several high-risk missions against them
including infiltrating their temple on
core ascent always prepared for a fight
cad carries ll-30 blaster pistols and
also some breathing tubes which means
that he's pretty much immune to force
choking heavily laced throughout the
clone wars he was actually missing from
rebels and though he was hinted at in
the series he didn't show up again until
a bad batch hunting omega aka boba
fett's sister he ran into fenix shand
and was defeated by her this somewhat
set up a rivalry with her and boba which
was also expanded upon in some of the
deleted clone wars episodes cad took
barbara under his wing but the pair
ended up turning on one another which
led to a duel of the fate the pair shot
each other at the same time and bane
actually put a dent in boba's helmet
which still remains there even though
his armor has been cleaned up though it
was never confirmed when bane later
returned in the bad batch he had a plate
on his head which he didn't have in the
main series this made it seem like he'd
indeed been shot and that the deleted
scene was in fact canon the play
actually appears later on in the episode
when his hack comes off and it ties in
with the scene and where he was hit now
bane tells him the bad news about band
but we do get to confirm later on that
he's still alive kind of figured this
out as he got shot in the shoulder so
fan theory right yes we're going down
with that one now like me when it comes
to a dh han solo bane can't really keep
his mouth closed as he also tells him
about the pikes killing the tuscans he
also clearly wants to get him riled up
so he can take him down whilst he's
thinking irrationally but boba refuses
to engage with him and though bane says
he's going soft it's the smarter route
to take as much as people are kind of
hating on how restrained boba is i think
that it shows maturity and how he's only
fighting when necessary as he's seen the
fallout that can be caused from this
across town the three families ambush
barbara's forces and though we thought
that would only happen when pigs fly
they actually take out the gamoreans
black chrysanthemum doesn't hold up too
well either and this leaves the mods
fighting the aqualish shand arrives to
save the day and using her sniper she
blasts one of them into a moisture
container which is it an aquapon
aqualish i don't know but moving on now
mando decides to remain with boba
because he buys into the bantha fodder
of the creed and though fett was never
raised amongst the mandalorians deep
down he does too they decide to both die
in the name of honor which hey that's
the name of the episode see you get the
best easter eggs here now the major
doormo says he can negotiate their safe
passage off world but bubba refuses to
do this this somewhat juxtaposes his
comments earlier in the season when he
was captured by the tuscans all that he
wanted to do was travel to anchor head
and escape but instead he's made a home
for himself here showing how much he's
grown he sends image dormo out to
negotiate nothing on his behalf and the
guy mentions obadiah several times which
is actually the homeworld of the pikes
he also brings up the flowered fields of
tatooine which according to the history
of the planet is what it used to look
like before it was turned into a harsh
desert the turskians have mentioned this
before and it's what boba wishes to see
the planet return to as we've discussed
in several of our videos george lucas
took a lot of inspiration from dune and
the desert planet arrakis was also a
lush tropical habitat until it was
harvested for spice it very much mirrors
that story and just in the same way that
an off wielder came to the planet and
saved it in paul boba wishes to do the
same thing this negotiation is of course
a distraction and boba and mano fly in
on their jetpacks taking the pikes out
we get some of the classic weapons used
by them including the whistling birds
which have popped up in the mandalorian
they hit one guy more times than you
should hit that like button and it's
nice to see fat actually doing something
for once the people of freetown arrive
in a v35 speeder which you may also
recognize from a new hope driving is the
weekway bartender played by w.l brown
who showed up in edward alongside
timothy elephant they have such good
attention to detail in this moment and
you can actually see the reflection of
the area and mando's helmet even though
it's cgi i don't know if they paid the
same attention to cad bane as i'm pretty
sure that you can catch the reflection
of the studio in his eyes but at least
they've done this year to kind of flesh
out the world the mods arrive and
there's a final shootout in the middle
of the town that feels like it was
ripped right out of the ending of butch
cassidy and the sundance kid the group
get a minor victory until some
scorpenectroids arrive and it all goes
down now these are pretty much the next
model up from the droid cares that we
saw in the prequel trilogy and they can
completely devastate an area in a matter
of seconds it feels like they're based
on ed209 from robocop and shout out
simon a bearman on twitter for sending
that comparison across they put their
shields up like the original droid akkis
did and even the jedi realized that they
had no chance with these barber tries to
use his jet pack rocket to no avail and
not even the dark saber can cut through
the barrier now both mando and sabine
have found the dark saber to be heavy
and difficult to use but what makes it
so heavy spoilers well in star wars
rebels season 3 episode 15 kanan trained
sabine and he explained why he said that
your thoughts and actions become energy
that flows through the crystals and
because of this you're able to wield it
as someone is trained in using the dark
saber and they focus their thoughts it
becomes lighter and easier to use to
properly wield the blade one must
understand themselves and be clear of
mind so that they can control it and
focus their mind into the energy this is
why mando found it difficult to wield as
his mind was unfocused but after groggy
shows up he finds it a lot easier amanda
was fighting against the blade instead
of fighting against his opponent but
grogu being here will now put things to
right this might even let him go forward
and become the leader of mandalore but
will have to wait until season three to
see if that plays out now luckily the
scorpene x are worse shots than
stormtroopers and chrysanthemum almost
breaks the shield in the comics when he
was taken in by the zonti brothers they
filled his hands with metal in order to
make him have permanent knuckle dusters
at one point he was electrocuted when
punching c3po i think because of this
he's decided to wear these external
knuckle dusters with a charge running
through them much in the same way that
in dune one must move slowly to break a
shield he tries to push through it but
the scorpenek just brushes him to the
side and he retains his title of being
the least valuable player pelly arrives
in a rickshaw and you might recognize
this as being something that padme and
anakin wrote on during attack of the
clones it also appeared in episode 3 and
is one of the best ways to get around on
tatooine with her she's brought a little
lad who jumps into his father's arms and
they probably have the most emotional
moment in the season so far the force
works in mysterious ways and grogu
massively helps in the fights later on
the rickshaw is destroyed and i love how
you can see pelly spit out one of her
teeth after the crash she actually has a
big gap in her smile for the rest of the
episode and it's hilarious how they have
this little moment now in all seems lost
we hear the giant footsteps of a beast
coming into town and yep you guessed it
your boy is back now boba riding on the
ranco was something that we all knew was
gonna happen but it's still so cool to
see it in the series this actually calls
back to the bad batch when his sister
omega also did the same thing with muchi
when it was first introduced by danny
trejo he paid lip service to the night
sisters of dathomir riding them which
ties into the expanded lore these
witches could tap into powerful dark
energies and they rode on top of the
beasts in order to terrify all that
opposed them bubba taming one is also
symbolic on a number of levels as it
ties into not only his past but also the
myths of the mandalorians bubba was
cloned from django fett and he like the
others was very much trained for battle
like the rancours they were bred for one
purpose but throughout the clone wars we
watched as they develop personalities
and deeper emotions this is mirrored in
the rancor who too has feelings and the
ability to form bonds with someone much
like how the clones created their own
brotherhood we also know that the
history of mandalore is filled with
stories of people fighting the great
beasts the mythosaur over time they
learned to tame these so that they could
ride them into battle and fed doing this
years somewhat mirrors the mandalorians
also doing this as a rite of passage the
mythosaur is very much embedded in their
culture and even the symbol of the
mandalorians is based around its skull
now they triple team the droid amando
manages to break through the shield
after hitting it with the dark saber
though the rancor is shot mano manages
to cut off the droid's weapon and
finally lower the shield which allows
grogu to step in using the force he
pulls one of the leg support bolts off
and this saves his dad and allows the
rancor to rip it apart back with the
mods drash gets a cycle rifle and heads
to the roof but she and her mate don't
have to hold that long before the rancor
arrives and cleans up the droids we
really see how ferocious they are and it
munches down on one of the pikes in a
similar way to how the one in jabba's
palace ate the gamorean we get a wilhelm
scream during the scene and it goes on a
really cool rampage cat arrives but
before he can turn him into lunch he
blasts out his flamethrower which is a
standard bounty hunter weapon that he
also used in the bad batch fedin can't
confirm a lot about their shared history
and there is lip service paid to his age
he's been a character that's appeared in
the prequel timeline original one and
also this one said after return of the
jedi so the guy is quite some age now
they do a quick draw that feels like it
was ripped right out of the deleted
clone wars episode but cad easily bests
him he mentions the first time he beat
him on a job and after he was trained by
django kad was very much seen as the
superior he says this is his final
lesson and in the deleted episode bane
was very much barbara's mentor before
the pair turned on one another barbara
is pretty much banged to right but he
uses the gaffy stick and manages to get
the upper hand the gaffi stick is of
course a weapon that was used by the
tuscans and it very much shows how
intrinsic they are to boba though he was
looked down upon for siding with them
without them he couldn't win and it
shows just how much they made him better
he apparently kills bane and though we
do get a long shot on his body we know
that it's possible for people to get
fixed up there's a weird lingering death
rattle as he goes out though and i do
think that this might be the last time
that we see the character in the clone
wars he of course killed several of the
clones and thus him being taken out by a
clone is sort of like poetry they rhyme
the rancor is on the loose and it rips
apart a landspeeder whilst those on the
ground fire up at it this moment feels
like it was ripped right out of king
kong but rather than it being beauty
that slide the beast it's baby baby
that's sleep the beast however mando
ends up fighting it first and the ranco
puts its helmet in its mouth which yeah
we've done enough helmet jokes this
season but there's one if you want it
you're dirty some of a [ __ ] now before
he flies up to fight it he gives grogu
the little round knob which you'll
probably recognize as being something
that he played with and constantly stole
in the mandalorian using the force grog
who calms the monster down and sends it
to sleep the little lad lies down too
and as we saw in the first season using
his powers tired grog go out pally says
guess it's not going to be a barbecue
and as we saw in the aftermath of the
crate dragon scene the people of
tatooine tend to eat what they kill
pelly even had some meat roasted over an
engine and i love this little call back
to the mandalorian season 2. next we cut
to most eyeslee and see the stormtrooper
helmets on spikes this is iconography
that showed up in episode 5 of the
mandalorian and also appeared earlier in
the season when boba passed pele on his
way to the pike leader he wants to just
cut and run but the other families and
mayors have made a deal all the forces
get shot the mayor gets hanged and fenix
stabs the leader in the back tidying up
all those loose ends out at the space
support people arrive once more to the
planet but this time there are no pikes
what we do get though is some pan-pak
music of the theme somewhat mirroring
the end of return of the jedi this
finally peace in the villages present
fruit as a tribute much like how don
corleone was given it by those he ruled
over in the godfather they now have a
crew which includes the bni 393 that you
will recognize from working at jabba's
palace earlier in the season instead of
the black melon from the desert that the
tuscans had they now get a real one and
we cut to space to see mando flying with
grogu in the astromech droid seat he
wants to go fast for any bangs on the
glass with the ball which is when the
pair fly off into season three now at
this point we get the credits but the
series does have a post-credits scene
whilst this doesn't set up a new show it
does confirm that cobb is alive as we
catch him in the back to tank he will be
back to fight again and there's also
thundercat there ready to start
operating on him it ends what was a
pretty solid episode and though i often
set myself up for disappointment with my
stupid fan theories on kira and the like
i did enjoy the way that things went i
feel like we had a lot of highs and
though it was more action than actual
plot development i think at this point
that's the way these shows are going to
go for their finales the last episode
did set things up to make us believe
that we were going to get a really crazy
entry and though there weren't any major
cameos i think it paid off in quite a
cool way now as for my thoughts on the
series i actually really enjoyed the
entire thing yes the entire thing
however that doesn't mean that there
weren't some lows and i do have my
criticisms with it being a show looking
at it as a whole it definitely feels
like two different seasons and i don't
need to point out where the obvious
shift change is i think that had they
just called the series star wars instead
of book above effect that people would
have been a lot kinder on it and
possibly they were trying to juggle too
many plots at once after rewatching it
from start to finish i do think that the
flashbacks somewhat affect the pacing
quite a lot and though i enjoyed them
it's a weird choice to juggle a past and
present storyline and then have a
completely different character come in
and take over the reigns now twitter
user adam fraser did a great thread
talking about how this is pretty much
still a boba fett show because every
character in it in some ways is
connected to him you have cobb van
through took his armor mano who was
saved by fett luke who ran into him
during return of the jedi and so on and
so forth everything pretty much revolves
around him and though he isn't
necessarily the central character now
without him the show doesn't have any
connectivity a book also defines that
it's something with branching chapters
and thus it does make sense that we
explore other people saying that though
this isn't a book it's a show and
therefore it does feel like it has some
issues with us pretty much just jumping
in and out of stories i still really
enjoyed it though even if the pandemic
affected it quite a lot and there were
several episodes i think were some of
the best star wars we've had in a long
time episode 2 worked brilliantly as a
metaphor for finding a home and
community and there's been several other
entries that have knocked it out the
park for me in the long run i'm glad
that they decided to do these other
routes though as i think the show would
have suffered if we just remain on
tatooine there was also the
technological achievements that the
series did as well the defect on luke
skywalker has pretty much set the bar
now in terms of what's expected from
digital characters i think going forward
people will often bring it up when
comparing whether future ones are as
good to sum it up i had a lot of fun
with it as i think it took long
established characters in interesting
new directions when a lot of places i
wasn't expecting it to and did fan
service that helped the story rather
than just being a cheap gimmick i know
it's had a lot of criticism but i
enjoyed what it did i'm trying to view
it for what it is rather than viewing it
for what i think it should have been i
can't wait to see where mandalorian
season 3 takes us and i hope that you've
enjoyed the breakdowns that we've done
on the series now obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the series so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are in competition right now giving
away three copies of june on the 28th of
feb and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the show we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of cad bane which will be
linked on screen right now we touched
upon certain parts of his backstory in
this episode but if you want a full
rundown of the character then definitely
go check it out right after this if not
then thanks for sticking through the
video i've been poor i'll see you in the
next one take care peace